after decades of limiting families to
just one child China has a new message
for couples please have another baby why
the change of heart
in short China is aging and losing its
working population although China
changed its rules in 2016 to allow
couples to have as many as two children
that hasn't convinced enough parents to
have more than one high living costs
long work hours and surging childcare
expenses means that many couples feel
that they can only afford to have one
child or even none on top of that a
study found that 33% of women had their
pay cut after giving birth and 36% were
demoted if they want to reverse the
demographic trends that they're
currently facing they will not only have
to deal with the cost of having a child
they'll also be fighting against
demographic and social trends in which
people are having fewer and fewer
children to counter that trend the
government is considering lifting all
limits on the number of children a
family can have otherwise by 2040 1/4 of
the world's most populous country will
be 65 or older which threatens an
economic boom that's been built on a
vast labor supply countries don't
usually become great powers when they're
old and graying they become great powers
when they're young and vigorous and if
Xi Jinping wants to complete that
transition he may need to build a
younger country that can pull it off how
did we get here after the creation of
the People's Republic of China in 1949
the government trained tens of thousands
of quote barefoot doctors to bring
health care to poor in rural areas the
result mortality rates plummeted and the
population growth rates skyrocketed by
the 1970s China was facing food and
housing shortages in 1979 its leader
Deng Xiaoping decided to limit most
couples to just one child and it worked
the average births per woman dropped to
less than two however there was a social
consequence to this the traditional
preference among Chinese parents / sons
caused many parents to abort female
kisses the imbalance grew to the point
where there were a hundred twenty men
for every 100 women over time women
became very picky about possible
husbands some rural men began to buy
wives from human traffickers in early
2018 authorities rescued 17 Vietnamese
women and arrested a gang of 60
traffickers who had been selling women
in China the change to allow two
children was meant to fix the nation's
demographic problems but after an
initial spike in the birthrate in 2016
the 2017 numbers didn't appear to be as
large the indications are that people
won't be rushing out to have kids they
may see a temporary bump in the number
of children but whether that will be a
lasting change that will affect China's
demographic trajectory seems very much
in doubt
you